[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning with families feeling the
squeeze the prime minister is preparing
to give his party conference speech on
tackling problems like the economy the
timing of it however is on the day the
universal credit uplift ends is raising
the minimum wage the answer we'll be
asking the justice secretary on the show
in just a few moments time plus as the
debate about women's safety and police
vetting continues we'll ask the former
chief constable of greater manchester
how you reform an institution like the
men
also on the show the former british
soldier arrested by the taliban last
month whilst trying to help hundreds of
afghans to leave while he has now been
flown out of afghanistan we'll be
speaking to him about his amazing story
just after 7 30. also to come
and reformers warning that more than a
hundred thousand pigs could be culled
rather than eaten this year due to a
shortage of butchers we'll ask two
farmers is the government making a pig
zero to this it is wednesday the 6th of
october
more guts less dithering boris johnson
will break with the past when he lays
out his vision for britain's future this
morning but what is his plan for hard-up
families
the universal credit uplift payment
officially ends today but what will it
mean for people in places like burnley
in lancashire where i am
they don't need this other nail in the
coffin sort of thing because it might be
the final mail for a lot of people if
this continues people are going to die
i'm at a petrol station in west london
which after days of being dry finally
has petrol and diesel we'll be looking
at the sky news data which reveals what
fueled the supply crisis
we hear from the victims of disability
hate crime amidst a spike in online
abuse
i've been told that i should have been
dropped to my head at birth i've been
told that i should have been aborted
i've been told that i'm a drain on
society to just die quickly
jurassic mark the new dinosaur found in
a welsh quarry thought to be related to
a t-rex but the size of a chicken
[Music]
morning all the prime minister will tell
his party today that he will deal with
the biggest issues that no government
has had the guts to tackle such as the
economy accusing his predecessors of
drift and dither his speech comes in the
day though that the universal credit
uplift ends sky's joel pike reports now
from manchester
this conference has truly been the boris
johnson show there's only one star in
town but whilst there's been a lot on
what he wants to do we're still waiting
for the how
i think it's time for him to move beyond
the rhetoric of levelling up to setting
out what that means and how he plans to
deliver it
i think what it means is a way of
delivering equality of opportunity i'm
looking forward to the pm speech i think
it's going to be uplifting it's going to
be clear about our journey and candidly
it's about delivering getting on with
the job as the female conference says
the prime minister is expected to say
after decades of drift and dither this
reforming government this can do
government that got brexit done is
getting the vaccine rollout done and is
going to get social care done we are
dealing with the biggest underlying
issues of our economy and society the
problems that no government has had the
guts to tackle before
among party members views are mixed
well i want to hear about the greening
up of the economy the freedom to act as
a country as an export nation
and international links i've been
working in health and social care for 21
years
and so i've seen the highs and lows of
health and social care so for me
you know i'm really looking forward to
the prime minister's speech around what
reforms not just the money because you
can put money at anything but we need
the reforms there we need to recruit
our own british doctors nurses i want to
hear about how we are going to support
the areas of deprivation we have
the leveling of the gender we want to
make sure that there are opportunities
for our youngest this conference has
been big on rhetoric but light on policy
after 11 years in power after brexit and
covid there is now a need for direction
and detail but it's not clear if forrest
johnson will deliver it
the speech is due to start at 11 30 joe
pike sky news manchester united
all right well clearly all eyes on the
conservative party conference today that
speech due at around about half past 11
as joe says lots of rhetoric has been
around this conference week in
manchester a number of announcements
perhaps though not as significant as
previous party conferences that might
have led you to believe
interestingly about the speech today we
will be seeing boris johnson in a rather
different format to that that other
cabinet ministers have had to enjoy they
have been in a somewhat smaller area
right next to the conference floor
allowing them that the joys of
addressing party faithful at the same
time as hearing what has been going on
in the conference floor instead we are
told that the prime minister will be
speaking in the round in the middle of
the room surrounded by the party
faithful one person who we must assume
will have a front row seat uh is the
justice secretary and of course at
deputy prime minister at dominic rav
let's bring him in from manchester now
mr ram really good to see this morning
how's conference been for you
well good morning look i i think uh it's
been great to get everyone back together
in person our message is that we're
building back better uh from this awful
pandemic and the government's getting on
with the job whether it's the
support for workers and employers
through the pandemic as we come out the
other side through to the reform of
social care and dealing with the nhs
backlog and the court's backlog which is
obviously dear to my heart given the
justice brief
indeed and we will move on to that in
just a second but you and i have spoken
an awful lot frankly over the past year
and a half largely however that has been
when you were occupying a slightly
different job that that of foreign
secretary many people saw your move to
justices as a demotion was there any
part of you aggrieved at the decision
that the prime minister made
no
um look
my job is to serve the government and
ultimately the country the prime
minister
has asked me to go back to the ministry
of justice where i've served twice
before um i've been given the role of
deputy prime minister which i'm honoured
to to do and frankly what i care about
most is delivering
on the court's backlog given the
aftermath of the appalling case of sarah
everard what more we can do to make
women feel safer and confident in the
criminal justice system
and rehabilitating offenders more
generally so to be honest with you all
of the media if you like side
show i just i tend to cut through and
just get on with the job
and it is a pretty tremendous job that
you have in front of you one has to say
tackling the problems with the courts
tackling the problems with the prisons i
just want to pick up on something though
that we heard from both
uh kit malt house the policing minister
and and indeed the prime minister
yesterday a degree of pushback on the
idea that the significant cuts that
there have been and you will concede
there have been significant cuts to
ministry of justice budget to the cps to
frontline policing to activity in the
courts that those cuts have had not had
any effect on the conviction rates
so first of all let's get the numbers
very straight since 2010 between 2010
and 2016 the moj budget the spend was
reduced by roughly a quarter that was us
dealing with the aftermath of the
economic crisis and the mess that the
labour party made of it from 2017 to
current day we increase the budget by
nine percent but it's not just about
money so for example if you look at uh
one of the measures that we're taking to
come through uh the backlog and in the
civil law system things like probate and
divorce we've had tremendous success in
a driving efficiency and better service
for those that use the justice system is
digitization and technology so yes
investment is important it's increased
by nine percent in my department since
2017 but there are other things it's the
way we do things that matter as well and
i think that's true for the experience
of whether it's witnesses victims or the
wider public of what they see and feel
of the criminal justice system
but just to pick you up in a specific
sentence construction you just used
there that it is not just to do with the
money i would agree with that it just
seems though that kit malt house
yesterday the prime minister yesterday
suggested that it's nothing to do with
the cut in the budgets that we've seen
at the moj
well we've had an increase in the budget
by 9 since 2017 so i'm making the point
that of course uh it's important to
invest in the right areas but you've got
to retain a responsible approach to the
public finances altogether and what i'm
also saying and that i've got the
advantage as you said neil coming back
to the moj um i was courts minister in
2018.
let me give you three examples gps
tagging
sobriety tags and virtual
giving of evidence or pre-recorded
giving evidence for vulnerable victims
in those three areas we've seen
game-changing shifts in the way the
courts and the justice system approach
matters and that is probably the most
exciting one of the most exciting things
and opportunities for me in terms of the
next two years because those things can
not only drive efficiencies and
allow us to invest in different ways
more effectively without just relying on
extra dollops of cash but also will
deliver for as i said vulnerable victims
witnesses and the average member of the
citizen that has very little and pretty
rare contact with the justice system a
much better service
just in terms of the of the sarah
everard situation and the inquiry that
is that has been set up why has that not
been put on a statutory footing as it is
the inquiry not in the statutory footing
cannot compel witnesses to attend cannot
compel witnesses to give testimony given
that one of the central accusations
against the met is that they close ranks
when one of their own is targeted surely
this needs to be put on a statutory
footing
i think what people want is a uh us to
get cracking on this uh as soon as
possible and to get to the truth the
inquiry
let's be clear this needs to be looked
at robustly vigorously without fear or
favor but i do also think that the
police as a whole and the vast majority
of uh of officers are appalled by this
and want to get those answers too and
therefore
describe this is dealing with it
robustly if we cannot compel people to
give testimony
we're not going to have a problem uh
getting uh to the truth of this because
i'm telling you i think the vast
majority of officers will want to
proactively support this but there are
two elements
the vast majority of officers will want
to contribute but of course you're not
suggesting that the bad eggs in the
metropolitan police or anything other
than a small minorities the small
minority we're talking about here
absolutely which is why
the inquiry and the review that the home
secretary announced will do first of all
find out why and how wayne cousins could
have risen through the ranks and
things like the flashing incidents and
all the other
if you like red flags that were going up
why they weren't taken more seriously
secondly it will look at
systemic issues cultural issues within
the police and i'm confident we will get
to the bottom of this and as justice
secretary will have a uh we're already
through the uh the the review of uh rape
uh cases and our violence against women
and girls strategy we're going to look
root and branch at everything
from
i'm talking about the experiences of
female victims and everything from the
time it takes to examine a mobile phone
in evidence right the way through to and
we're already doing this protecting
vulnerable
victims giving evidence in court so you
don't find that on top of the appalling
ordeal physical and mental trauma
they've been through that the justice
system isn't compounding that with the
way that they're treated so we will look
at everything from top to bottom and i
look i've said it's my number one
priority to make sure women feel
confident in the justice system and
confident in being able to walk the
streets without having to look over
their shoulder in fear
let's talk about the the prime minister
the man to whom you are of course in
your new role as deputy prime minister
number two uh what are we to to make of
the emphasis this week on wage growth on
wage growth as being
not the be all and end all but certainly
an overwhelming priority for the prime
minister
is known in government concerned
that wage wage growth goes hand in hand
with an increase in inflation
well look there's clearly as we go
through the pandemic this issue of
inflation but
the forecasts show that
after the this year it comes back down
and of course the bank of england has a
mandate to target two percent but the
paradigm shift we're seeing in the
economy something that was much
discussed during the brexit referendum
but as part of as we come through the
pandemic uh the prime minister's
overriding priorities we've got a great
record on bringing down unemployment
raising employment the number of
vacancies uh being advertised for those
who are coming off benefits or who have
been
furloughed is is remarkable two million
more jobs than were expected but we also
need to make sure people can afford to
live
can afford to pay the bills and
that's why with real wages rising so
over and above inflation on the latest
quarterly figures uh six and a half
sorry six percent above inflation
compared to the same time last year with
the national living wage extended uh
saving the average worker eligible 4 000
pounds a year it is critically important
and what we are also saying is we want
our vision is a high employment high
skilled high-wage economy but not that
is going to take an awful long time
but it's going to take some time to get
to and it's certainly going to take a
lot longer than for example a decision
the prime minister could make like that
and not take 20 pounds a week off of
some of the poorest working family 20
pounds a week of some of the poorest
working families in the country i mean
the statistics on this are really weird
we'll get ian duncan smith in the
program later on and he will rail
against this and the reason is 4.4
million households with 3.5 million
children will see their incomes drop by
more than a thousand pounds according to
the resolution foundation why are we
doing this
so first of all we carried uh and
supported the government supported 40
million people
through furlough through this pandemic
we extended universal credit and that
was always intended to be temporary i've
explained to you the national living
wage we've also uh made sure that we
through uh the extension the purse
allowance personal allowance for income
tax saving every worker 1200 pounds
a year but just specifically on uc we
also announced to get people off that
risk of long-term unemployment and
benefit reliance including uc a two
billion pound
kickstart package just one of the uh the
400 billion pound measures uh that the
chancellor has introduced so we are
saying that of course the welfare system
is there for those most in need but what
we want to do in this two pound billion
pounds going into the kickstart scheme
it's been extended is supporting people
off benefits into work that must be
right over the longer term
these aren't back of a [ __ ] packet
calculations i mean the legatum
institute says that the extra support
has protected 840 000 people from
poverty in the second quarter of this
year including and again i know it's a
motive to mention but 290 000 children i
mean what is your message directly to
those who will be moved into poverty as
a result of the ending of the 20 pounds
a week uplift today
well of course the the emergency support
we provided was because of the pandemic
as we come through the pandemic with
youth unemployment going down employment
going up we need to transition we don't
want to see people reliant on the
welfare trap we want to where it's
possible and i know for not everyone if
someone's got a disability that it'll
different set of circumstances there's
targeted support there but where it's
possible the right thing to do as we
come through this pandemic we've got uh
employment rising vacancies at a record
high university are either in work or
looking for work though mr rabb i don't
understand this argument
and and and that's why
with wages through the national living
wage with the personal income tax with
uh not relying on the cheap drug of
skilled of unskilled labor from abroad
our overall driving force of the
economic plan is to see wages go up and
they have gone up and and i just cited
to you the figures um the the annualized
figures for the latest quarter that real
wages over inflation have increased by
six percent we've got to start
the latest ons explanation and it says
six percent uh if you strip out bonuses
uh and those that get an uplift it's
four and a half percent those are the
figures the latest figures that the ons
uh have provided but look the bottom
line is the government wants uh to
including increase and promote the job
creation that we've seen that's relying
on the entrepreneurs we want to support
the most vulnerable but we've also got
to transition people into higher paid
jobs that is the sustainable long-term
solution and i don't see any other party
with a credible alternative uh mr rob we
will be speaking again in the very near
future i'm sure good to see you this
morning thanks being with us
thank you
uh well we were just discussing it there
the 20 pounds a week universal credit
uplift ending today the government
has as you just heard defended the
payments withdrawal saying that
taxpayers should not be subsidising low
wages through the benefits system our
community's correspondent lisa holland
reports now from burnley
hello
reporter won't come on
james anderson fears calls to his free
heating and plumbing service will rise
by 50 this winter and a big part of that
will be down to the changes in universal
credit
families are under the enough pressures
of this children that are not pleasing
as it is they don't need this other nail
in the coffin sort of thing because it
might be the final nail for a lot of
people if this continues people are
going to die simple as that
that's quite a stark warning it is it's
the truth people are going to die simple
as that
and the south factory could be children
he's been a plumber for more than 20
years but the rising cost of living has
prompted james to start giving out food
parcels he's come to see lynton lockett
who says he's already struggling to feed
his family even before the loss of the
weekly 20 pound uplift payments you're
just about pushing yourself in the
positives to pay things
and leaving you enough
but then when you take that
you to you to work out everything else
again
and before you know it you've more less
money for your shopping
less money for your kids
and it's it is it's a losing battle
you can see the floor just went moldy
from where
everything was leaking because even my
washer started leaking from underneath
it's not just food that linton needs
help with a leaking tap in his kitchen
has caused moldy floors and walls and an
infestation of fruit flies
so i try not to like do
how do you feel about that
well i get embarrassed
because i'm obviously not your fault i'm
not used to well
it's not my mouth
are you horrified about this yes i am
to buy a ball it's something that needs
to be dealt with when it does you can't
ignore it you can't leave it like this
forever
there are a lot of people in burnley who
need james's help nearly a quarter of
working age people here are on universal
credit including kelly constant
the difference between me eating with
the kids or having a couple of pieces of
toast or something for tea
but the government says the uplift
payments were only ever meant to be a
temporary measure and is offering
support to get people to increase their
working hours lisa holland sky news
burnley
uh more on that throughout the show but
let's just bring you a little sky news
data analysis now
around the petrol supply crisis we can
see
when panic buying at petrol stations
began when you look at this graph here
with the rapid change in demand leading
to shortfalls and fuel stock held at
petrol stations the average volume of
fuel being sold per transaction well you
can just see it there it jumped by more
than four liters on the day that we saw
panic buying begin
at the start of the crisis ten days ago
the number of trips to petrol stations
while it was almost five times higher
than normal and although the crisis is
easy we are still seeing more trips to
the petrol station than before uh
including one made by our correspondent
laura bundik who joins us now uh laura
good to see you this morning and oh well
it looks like you've actually managed to
find one of the four courts that has you
i have they're becoming a more common
more common sight as well neil yeah this
petrol station in west london didn't
have fuel for over a week but it finally
has and i think those empty pumps are
becoming less and less frequent things
look are looking up at the moment but if
you start to look at the data we get a
real picture of why panic buying led to
such steep falls in fuel stocks firstly
if you look at the underground storage
beneath these four courts it's normally
at 40 percent but as panic buying set in
it went down to 16.6
and customers were buying more fuel we
normally buy 24.5 liters
but with panic buying this went up to
29.82 liters that extra five liters
might not sound much but when you
combine that with a nearly trebling of
customers then you can see why there
were shortages uh if you look at the
navigation data as well it shows that
there was a 190
increase in people driving to petrol
stations on the 22nd to the 29th of
september and the reason the system
couldn't cope is because four courts
operate on a just-in-time model it means
they're usually resupplied as they're
about to go dry it's a very cost
effective way of working but the problem
is if you combine a change in demand
panic buying with a shortage of drivers
then you have a big issue like i say
things are starting to improve at the
moment it might be easier to buy fuel
now neil but the bad news is it's also
more expensive both petrol and diesel
prices are now rising
many thanks indeed
still to come on the show this morning
uh farmers well they're warning that
more than a hundred thousand pigs could
be culled because of a shortage i'll be
speaking to two pig farmers in just a
few minutes
then after that i'll be speaking to the
former british soldier ben slater who
was arrested and then released by the
taliban
and then
what are the eight promising trials from
a revolutionary depression treatment
that sends electrical pulses to
stimulate the brain i'll be discussing
the findings with the professor of
neuroscience
i think it's safe to say it has not been
a particularly good week for facebook's
ceo mark zuckerberg
not only has his company been hit by its
worst ever outage but he's also very
exciting serious allegations from a
former employee francis hogan about its
approach to safeguarding children uh
well mr zuckerberg is now hit back in a
blog post
saying this it's difficult to see
coverage that misrepresents our work and
our motives at the most basic level i
think most of us just don't recognize
the false picture of the company that is
being painted he released these words
after the accusation against his company
found their way to washington yesterday
when ms hogan had an audience with the
us senate here's what she told them
yesterday we saw facebook get taken off
the internet
i don't know why i went down but i know
that for more than five hours facebook
wasn't used to deepen divides
destabilize democracies and make young
girls and women feel bad about their
bodies facebook has repeatedly misled
the public
about what its own research reveals
about the safety of children
the efficacy of its artificial
intelligence systems and its role in
spreading divisive and extreme messages
the prime minister's high representative
for afghanistan simon gas has met senior
taliban leaders in the country it's the
first meeting between british officials
and the new taliban leadership
the british delegation held talks with
senior taliban officials including
foreign minister and deputy prime
minister they discussed how the uk can
help with the humanitarian crisis and
prevent terrorism as well as ensuring
the safety of those wishing to leave
afghanistan
taiwan's defense minister says china
will be capable of mounting a full-scale
invasion of taiwan in the next four
years it comes just days after record
numbers of chinese aircraft flew into
the country's air defense zone part of a
pattern of what taipei calls beijing's
continued harassment taiwan's defense
minister says tensions with china are
the worst they've been in more than 40
years
let's take a quick look at the latest
cover data for the uk
there have been a further 33 869 new
cases reported
166 people have died after contracting
covert that takes the total number of
people who've lost their lives within 28
days of a positive test of course at 237
152
uh these are once again remarkable live
images of the volcano on the spanish
island of la palma still throwing ash
and lava into the air after first
erupting more than two and a half weeks
ago
the volcano increased its explosive
power yesterday roaring louder and
pushing thicker lava out of its main
vents
around a thousand homes have so far been
destroyed
and a quick look at the impact of
climate change on the planet the top
line showing you how the uk's power is
being generated just a quarter this
morning coming from fossil fuels and
then you can see the rise in global
temperature since records began
then the estimated time till an increase
of one and a half degrees celsius
at the point of no return according to
many climate scientists and then at the
bottom the total carbon dioxide
emissions in millions of tons
you can get all the latest on the sky
news daily climate show
that's every evening monday to friday at
half past six
now there's been a dramatic increase in
online hate crimes against disabled
people in the last year according to
police figures obtained by two charities
leonard cheshire and united response
said there were more than 9 000
disability hate crimes reported to
police in england and wales but one the
problem is likely to be worse due to
under-reporting the crime prosecution
service says it's committed to tackling
all hate crime sky's shaman freeman
powell reports
kerry thompson is a busy woman she's an
activist a blogger and a part-time
charity worker
but in her spare time she finds herself
trawling through hate
left by faceless abusers online i've
been told that i should have been
dropped my head at birth i've been told
that i should have been aborted
i've been told that i'm a drain on
society so just die quickly
it's not necessary
and kerry is not alone
figures published by leonard cheshire
and united response reveal that online
hate soared by more than 50 across
england and wales
and when people like kerry speak up she
says nothing good comes out of it
i reported it
to
the social media platform that i got the
online hateful to then get a message
back 24 hours later to say that it
didn't
go against any of their guidelines
the hate isn't just online it's offline
too
according to charities in-person
disability hate is also on the rise
something becky batten is all too
familiar with
recently last year when i went to get
some petrol and just as i was sort of
standing filling the car up a lot behind
and there was two women in the car
behind
at the kind of windscreen with their
phones filming me
um you know gratuitously they saw me
look at them they didn't care they just
carried on
charities say that when it is reported
to police there are very few
prosecutions
the one thing that's most shocking um is
that only one percent of disability hate
crimes are actually being charged or
making it to the cps and that's
something that really has to change and
one thing we're asking for is for there
to be specialist disability liaison
officers and police forces
the charities want the police to have a
better understanding of disability hate
crimes and to take them seriously
so people like becky
and kerry can live a life without hate
shaman freeman powell sky news
story of the day this one scientists
have identified the oldest known
meat-eating dinosaur from the uk the
pendrig milner was the size of a modern
chicken not that scary would have been
about one meter long with its tail uh it
lived around well over 200 million years
ago in what is now wales its name means
chief dragon in middle welsh i'll need
to work on the pronunciation for next uh
we will be speaking to someone from the
natural history museum about this
fantastic story a little later in the
programme but coming up after the break
i'll be speaking to the former british
soldier arrested by the taliban last
month who has now been released
[Music]
welcome back the deputy prime minister
dominic rabb has told the programme he's
not worried about rising inflation
that's the government pledges to
increase wages mr rabb says that
inflation is on its way down at some
point
well look there's clearly as we go
through the pandemic this issue of
inflation but uh the forecasts show that
after the this year it comes back down
and of course the bank of england has a
mandate to target two percent but the
paradigm shift we're seeing in the
economy something that was much
discussed during the brexit referendum
but as part of as we come through the
pandemic the prime minister's overriding
priorities we've got a great record on
bringing down unemployment raising
employment the number of vacancies uh
being advertised for those who are
coming off uh benefits or who have been
uh furloughed is is remarkable
uh let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen joining us
once again from the tory conference in
manchester it's almost over tomorrow
you'll be able to get home soon um but
before that we've got the little matter
of the prime minister's speech
that's right and dominic rob really
echoed what we expect to be the prime
minister's quite breezy message that
inflation may go up the cost of living
the cost of everything in the shops may
go up but it will probably come down
again next year and this is just
something we have to get through what
the prime minister called the stresses
and strains of transitioning making a
hugely important transition to a higher
wage economy boris johnson will be
saying today that only he has had the
guts to actually do this previous prime
ministers and he hints that they are
both labour and conservative have not
had the guts to say let's not have any
more of what he calls the cheap drug of
low-skilled migration he wants people to
have better paid jobs and businesses to
invest in those of course that does jar
with what's happening outside this
conference hall people's bills going up
some of their benefits being taken away
he is gambling that that will all be
just a temporary hitch and that the
economy will keep on growing next year
and everyone will feel the benefits of
it there are some mps who are worried
that it may not work out that way
they certainly are tomorrow for now
thank you
pig farmers they've been warning that
more than a hundred thousand animals
could be culled this year due to labour
shortages they're calling on the
government to help stabilize the supply
chain to avoid what they're calling the
emotional and indeed financial disaster
of needlessly killing thousands of pigs
i'm joined now by two pig farmers kate
and vicky moore okay vicky lovely to see
you both this morning and i think i even
see one of the pigs in the background as
well
lots of them well just just just bring
us up to date with with the situation as
regards your farm have you been put in
the position so far of having to cull
any of your animals
okay so um we're really doing a juggling
act i suppose you'd say at the moment
with our animals um we are filling every
shed that we've got um and we
are basically emptying a shed on a
monday and refilling it on a tuesday
whereas before it would normally have
two weeks to rest
wash out disinfect so we're doing
everything that we possibly can to avoid
having to kill pigs on farm because
are you anticipating that you may well
get to that point in the in the
immediate future
we're weeks away from it being an
absolute disaster so uh we are pleading
with the government to do something to
relax
the visas and allow some uh eu people
back in to do the skilled butchery jobs
we're desperate
we heard from the prime minister
yesterday that he doesn't think that
it's his job it's not the prime
minister's job to to sort out supply
chain issues and that industries like
agriculture like livestock you know it's
down to you to try and sort this out
that you've had all the time that you
knew this was coming
that's really easy for you guys to say
we we get a contract from the processors
um so we are contracted to sell x amount
of pigs every every year and that
contract hasn't changed brexit came and
went and we still had the contract this
is not a farmer's problem this is
further up the supply chain that should
have been dealt with before now and
we're the ones left with the emotional
and the financial hit which is gonna
it's gonna
bring us financially and emotionally
it's horrendous no one should be forced
to kill healthy animals uh when there's
imports coming in of cheap meat that are
filling the supermarket shelves it's an
absolute disgrace
have have you ever been in the position
before where you have had to cull
healthy animals in that way
no because it's barbaric it's wrong you
know there's people starving in this
world and
the prime minister
is prepared to just allow healthy pigs
to go to waste it's an absolute joke
it's it's it's criminal how can this be
yeah it's just absolutely ridiculous and
it's not the farmer's fault he's
punishing the farmers we're farmers to
produce food to feed the country for
god's sake you know we've got our labor
our staff we we've got our working
conditions we've got people who enjoy
doing the job it's not our problem this
but it's been forced upon us and it's us
they've got to deal with them and forest
johnson needs to remember that we are
unsubsidized we have never been
subsidized the pig industry and we um we
are high wage payers and we're exporters
you know he needs to realize that we
actually do bring quite a lot to this
country and he needs to support us right
now
um kate vicki you you've both mentioned
during our conversation that the
emotional impact that that culling your
animals would have uh have on you i come
from quite an agricultural agricultural
part of the country i understand the
link between farmers and and their
livestock but for those who haven't been
blessed with that upbringing just
explain why you feel
you might feel so emotional about it
because we care about them yeah we're
still producing we're producing food but
it doesn't mean that we don't care about
what we do you know
the relationship is is just ingrained
you can't
it's not a dis respect from every part
and it's just been destroyed
do you feel that the prime minister has
taken this as seriously as he might i
mean he was speaking on times radio
yesterday uh asked about the crisis that
you and other farmers are feeling and he
said i'm afraid they're eating very
often in this country i don't know do
you have a bacon sandwich i mean what do
you make of comments like that from the
man who's running the country at the
moment
he's just a buffoon to be quite honest
if he does not understand the difference
between culling a pig in an abattoir and
killing and incinerating a pig on top
which will not go into the food chain
i mean we've got no hope have we it's
just absolute ignorance and whether he's
done it intentionally or not it just is
a complete disregard for for farming pig
farmers especially but actually farming
in general because like i say we're
producing food to feed the blooming
nation we worked all the way through
covered there was no no subsidies no
furlough for us we kept day on day day
in day out
doing what we do to produce food to fill
the supermarket shelves
which now is just being filled by eu
products it's crazy because we haven't
got our border controls sorted yet the
eu sorted thirds on the first of january
um kate vicki we're about to run out of
time we've heard from them but we
haven't yet seen perhaps the most
important people in this interview the
pigs that i'm presuming are just down by
your feet or just behind you i'm
wondering if we can have a quick look
they're all just waking up they're very
chilled out
lucky them lucky them um kate moore
vickimer great to have you on the
program this morning thanks very much
for speaking to us
thank you
now a former british soldier arrested by
the taliban last month has now been
flown out of afghanistan ben slater was
trying to help hundreds of people leave
the country and i'm very pleased to say
uh ben slater joins us now he is also
the chairman of the nomad concepts group
and he is with us now from doha ben
great to have you on the program this
morning um just wondering how you're
feeling to be out of afghanistan
uh good morning uh yes um obviously it's
uh it's it's it's it's nice to obviously
be out and um obviously in qatar and uh
safe and well
how were you treated um by the taliban
clearly there was going to there was
considerable concern
about risks to your own personal safety
i'm just wondering how you found
ahead the past few weeks
uh okay i mean obviously uh as you're
probably aware um i've been
with them for uh well as of yesterday
for approximately five weeks um so
actually uh about five weeks in total so
the first two weeks um uh be being
honest was uh not not too pleasant so
basically what happened was
is that uh when i was obviously
initially arrested um and uh obviously
we was held in torque um for three days
in a jail there's like a concrete cell
um basically just sitting on the floor
um
and that was obviously um in in in
isolation and captivity for three days
there where the initial interrogation
started um and then basically from there
i was moved then to a uh a detention
prison as a jail
which was obviously used for
interrogation and uh of uh
more of the exotic uh kind of uh you
know criminals or people that you know
needed those facilities to be detained
so i was there for uh two weeks and that
those two weeks were pretty pretty bad
conditions um
what it was is that they'd obviously
picked up on the fact that i was i was
ex-military and naturally that led to
them thinking that i was obviously uh
you know like a james bond type
character basically um so as soon as
that was um
mentioned uh that i was possibly mi or
mi5 uh basically i lost a lot of my
rights i lost a lot of my um you know
sort of uh sort of dignity basically for
a couple of weeks uh so there was uh a
bit of obviously um you know there was a
few um aggressive actions uh the the
jail cell was basically on a par
with uh like uh what they kept
mentioning guantanamo bay uh the
conditions are quite similar uh it was
very hot it was very crowded uh and it
was very very unusual for me to be in
that situation because
you know um
it was very much like that for two weeks
uh completely isolated no communication
uh you know bag over the head handcuffs
moved around you know obviously a couple
of uh you know a couple of let's just
say uh beatings uh let's just be honest
okay everyone's aware of it someone's
gonna say it um and then of course then
there was the interview phases and
getting moved around
and obviously
it was unusual for me because obviously
the situation uh was
at that point for me pretty dire because
obviously i knew that this wasn't good
and uh there was no way i could get any
communication out i was in
the same uh
jail as basically you know unfortunately
there was uh is in there there was daesh
in there there was obviously some pretty
nasty criminals in there but obviously
the taliban were also processing so for
me it was a really unusual environment
to be in um then after the the two weeks
of that uh basically
uh uh the the actual the the director uh
dr bashir uh the main sort of head in
the jalalabad uh sort of uh area
covering the nangarhar province uh which
talk and falls under uh he obviously uh
he realized that yes obviously i was
ex-military and yes i was obviously
evacuating uh afghan women
out of the country uh my staff
mainly and their families
and basically but he did a determined
that i wasn't what he initially thought
i was so after that two week points
which was useful i suspect ben which was
really which was incredibly useful and
and then the the the treatment change i
i have to ask though you you you came
out of afghanistan i think on the same
plane that sir simon gas was on the the
uk's high representative to afghanistan
i mean were they there
to negotiate your release or had that
already been secured agreed
before they spoke to the taliban
leadership
okay i mean look um i'd like to say
obviously that the uh the the home
office and the fcdo and obviously the uk
government and the agencies involved
it's been absolutely fantastic i mean
obviously now i'm getting aware of what
was actually done so basically uh in
regards to simon gas and the uh deputy
ambassador or the ambassador now in
exile
we're basically there obviously having
meetings about the uh the delegation
come in uh regarding the humanitarian
issues and maybe how
there could be possible engagement in
the future to help the afghan people
okay
and basically i think obviously they
took the opportunity
uh because i was there obviously when
they come in i think i was used not used
i would say i was like a trojan horse to
maybe start that dialogue and to say
like oh can you also release uh benjamin
so that was why it was all very quick
for me because
um not only was the uh the
the british ambassador has done a
fantastic job in qatar doha and
obviously simon bass and the deputy
ambassador in
exile for afghanistan
and the home office also the british
high commissioner in and the consulate
team had put a very creative plan in
place to get me to islamabad as well so
there was basically two
embassies and the home office and
everyone was working as a collective and
i must admit when i arrived i was very
surprised i was very rushed i didn't
know what was happening i didn't even
know where i was going at that point and
obviously to see
simon bass and uh martin the um
the ambassador in exile that was
obviously having the negotiations
obviously some of it was about me and
somebody was about the massive
humanitarian issues that are ongoing ben
we're really pushed for time i just want
to squeeze in a quick question you it's
great that you have made it and we're
very very pleased on your behalf and
indeed for for your friends and family
but one of those left behind you're a
former serviceman yourself you
understand the role that the
interpreters played on the ground in
afghanistan for us there are still lots
of them waiting to come out of the
country
yeah i mean there's obviously a lot of
people still there
obviously i am having beginning dialogue
with uh multiple countries including the
uk to obviously organize visas uh and to
obviously get some more of these at risk
out but they're still in so obviously
there was a bit of miscommunication when
i was initially arrested obviously
we still managed to get 112 people out
okay so we were very successful
now we are
trying to basically
um organize visas through the email
system through various governments we're
hoping the uk canada usa australia and
the european countries do
kindly get in touch or i can engage them
and maybe get a few from each country
and then i can finish off the amount
that are left behind
they're currently obviously keeping a
low profile and they are
they're informing me every day
um ben i'm so sorry that we have to
leave it there but as i said really good
to have you out of the country and and
and hope you continue to be well thanks
for joining us thank you so much
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
britain will have a mostly dry and sunny
morning after early rain clears norfolk
ireland and northern ireland meanwhile
we'll see cloud and outbreaks of rain
spreading in it'll be a bit warmer cloud
and rain will spread to western britain
during the afternoon heavy and
persistent over western scotland while
ireland and northern ireland will see
patchy rain giving way to occasional
drizzle
clean air spreading from the atlantic
means that the air pollution index where
one means low pollution and 10 means
very high will be low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
it was like my lens on the world changed
that's how the first person in the world
who was given a groundbreaking new
technology to treat her depression
describe the results the device acts as
a pacemaker for the brain which emits
small electrical pulses to keep the
patient from falling into depressive
states let's talk more about this with
professor of neuroscience and mental
health jonathan roizer who's been
researching depression treatments at
university college london professor
lovely to see you this morning so
explain exactly what this impact this
implant is and and how exactly it works
yeah thanks very much for having me on
so this is really a step forward in the
deep brain stimulation technology as
applied in depression what the research
team have done here is borrowed
techniques from other areas of
functional brain surgery as it's called
and done an amazing piece of work in
this one patient obviously very
preliminary results but what they've
managed to do is to map the different
regions where the symptoms may be coming
from in terms of the neural activity so
they uh initially mapped these ten
regions they found one region
which seemed to correspond to the
symptoms on a sort of day by day basis
called the amygdala
and then they had an implant in a
different region called the ventral
striatum
where they found that if they stimulated
that could regulate
activity in the amygdala
so that was the first step which is
different to usual
and then the final step is this closed
loop approach which is really the
technological advance where the
stimulator and the recording device are
hooked up together via a bluetooth
connection
and then the stimulator only turns on
when excessive activity in the amygdala
is actually detected and it just does a
short burst i think they said six
seconds in the paper and that seemed to
be enough uh to stop the patient's
depressive symptoms emerging
i mean professor
it's clearly working for sarah she is
raving about this particular treatment
but i have to admit my first thoughts
when when reading about this went
straight to you know electric shock
therapy which was for a while used or
perhaps even still is used in treating
some kind of mental conditions this
seems a country mile away from that
though yeah well i should say that
electric shock therapy or ect is
sometimes called is still uh used um
certainly in in the uk and the usa many
other countries and it can be incredibly
effective so i wouldn't want to talk it
down but it is a much a much more
blunt tool than this
there are other forms of brain
stimulation including ones that you can
do non-invasively uh one's called
transcranial magnetic stimulation
but this one really does the um
application of the uh stimulation
directly into the brain circuit that we
think is uh responsible so it's really
incredibly precise and when the surgeons
are putting these stimulators in uh
they're aiming you know for a millimeter
cubed piece of tissue so it's a totally
different uh totally different type of
stimulation
um professor roy i'm sorry it was a
short and sweet interview but i'm glad
that we had you on thank you so much for
joining us thank you
stay with us after the break we will
return to that interview with the
justice secretary dominic rabb
[Music]